you're in a city ten thousand fathoms
beneath the sea
it's quite beautiful
living under the sea isn't just
hollywood fantasy requesting landing
clearance over
can we build an underwater city sure
whether we build them to survive
overpopulation or catastrophic climate
change
or to help scientists learn more about
our planet
it stands to reason that we must push
the boundaries of ocean exploration so
that we can bring back
solutions the deepsea could teach us
about our own origins and if we can
learn about how life originated here
we might be able to learn something
about how life may have originated
elsewhere
we already know more about the surface
of the moon than the depths of our
oceans
in comparison to going to the moon
living underwater is not that
[Music]
complicated
while our relationship with the ocean
started tens of thousands of years ago
the technology that enabled humans to
explore underwater
is relatively recent in 1943
a french naval officer called jacques
cousteau invented
the aqualung the precursor to scuba
in his 1964 film world without sun
he explored the sea in his two-man
submarine the diving saucer
he'd park it in a garage which was part
of his sub-aquatic village
these men are the first ocean oats
they are going to live down here for a
month
his team spent 30 days beneath the waves
these sunken houses permit us to escape
many limitations of diving
more habitats followed built by amateur
enthusiasts
as well as serious players such as the
us navy and nasa
the sea was the next frontier to be
explored and there was interest from
beyond the scientific community
president kennedy wrote to the u.s
senate in 1961
knowledge of the oceans is more than a
matter of curiosity
our very survival may hinge on it
in the 1950s and 60s that particular
time period
there's a historical context there that
makes
underwater living particularly desirable
so there
are military applications and this is
the birth of the offshore oil industry
and various underwater construction
projects and then you also have the
third reason which is perhaps less of an
incentive and that's
that marine biology is starting to
develop what indeed are the limits on
flesh and blood
beneath the waves were people looking at
the physiological effects on the body
as opposed to say the the scientific
work that could be done
from those debts so one of the problems
in underwater habitats
is that you have to change the gas
mixture
that can be breathed safely at a depth
if you just breathe normal air
that we breathe here or if you breathe
pure oxygen it becomes toxic or you get
nitrogen narcosis
so they had to combine different types
of gas to
breathe at pressure and they were
breathing helium mixtures
and nitrogen mixtures which is why when
you watch videos of these aquanauts they
always have that high helium voice
the seas remain largely unexplored
because of the limits of the human body
we can only dive for a few hours every
breath of compressed air
depth requires decompression after be it
in a chamber
or by slowly rising back up to the
surface without it
divers can develop decompression
sickness also known as the bends
where nitrogen in your bloodstream
begins to bubble damaging blood vessels
and blocking blood flow it's potentially
lethal
so living in an underwater habitat like
cousteau's aquanauts
the body stays saturated with inert
gases
enabling them to dive and work without
decompression
if man need not return to the service
periodically taking a long time to
decompress those potentially fatal
bubbles within his body
he can be infinitely more productive
down below
but one of the problems is that as soon
as you have your breathing you're
living in a helium atmosphere it um is
not very good for
temperature control at all and if you're
living in the ocean you can imagine it's
quite cold so one of the pro
one of the problems that they had to
figure out how to adapt to was
that the divers are constantly cold
they're freezing in this
uh helium atmosphere and then the other
problem is that
once you're staying at depth for a
prolonged period so unlike a submarine
where you can go up purge the air and go
back down
you have to develop some sort of air
circulation system that is purging co2
constantly and that
only really works well if you can keep
the humidity down
if you're living in a metal container
under the ocean it's difficult to keep
the humidity down
so controlling all of these atmospheric
conditions was one of the really big
hurdles um for making it safe for people
to live at death
a lot of these habitats came and went in
the 60s and 70s can you
give us some sense of the historical
context in the 1960s and the 1970s this
is when the
space race is going on so there was this
analog between the exploration of inner
space
the oceans and outer space and
already in the us um
people in in government in nasa and in
the navy were looking ahead to future
space exploration missions
and thinking that here under water we
have a perfect analog example where we
can already study how crews are going to
behave
uh in isolation in a small space over
long periods of time so the cold war is
a really important context for
understanding this as well
and the russians were going into space
and there were a few soviet habitats but
they never
seemed like a viable um
real competition to the to the americans
so
underwater competition between the
americans and the soviets
played out with nuclear submarines but
not underwater habitats nobody was
colonizing the sea floor
i think the technology was proven in the
1960s and 70s but
there were other reasons that it wasn't
that useful or proved
to not be something that was necessary
to do for a long period of time
the technology developed that allowed
divers to compress
on shipboard instead instead of at depth
it will take two and one half hours for
their bodies to be equal to the same
pressure they will experience on the
ocean floor
so you could be compressed in a
compression chamber in a ship
then lowered in a capsule while still
under pressure
exit the capsule work on the oil head
rig get back in the capsule and remain
pressurized at the surface
and that technology did develop out of
all of these experiments with underwater
habitats
but it sort of took the underwater
habitats out of the equation
scientists still see value in spending
time under the sea
what sort of questions are they trying
to answer my wife is a marine
microbiologist um
is actually here if you want to ask her
questions about this
yeah i'd be great all right
hi hi i am a marine microbiologist
mostly focusing on hydrothermal vents
um and i've been doing that for a while
now and my advisor my phd advisor was
the one who first suggested that the
origin of life may have been in
hydrothermal events
yeah that's one of humanity's big
questions i guess so
you know do you think those answers
could be at the bottom of the c
we'd like to think so um the original
idea basically was that hydrothermal
vents are kind of like a natural
laboratory because they're dominated by
gradients
so in the middle of a chimney it's
really hot it's water it can be up to
400 degrees celsius and then two feet
away the water is like two degrees
celsius right so
in between you have every temperature
you could possibly want for all kinds of
reactions
they're very hard to study because
they're at the bottom of the ocean
thousands of meters deep and we can only
really take samples when we can get a
ship out there
if you had the opportunity to spend say
a month underwater next to one of these
vents
from a scientific angle would that be
helpful
yeah so there's there's two answers
there one is we do use submarines so i
have been there um i've been in alvin
down to the
these vents and and being there in
person is amazing because you get a much
better sense of what the environment
looks like in a three-dimensional way
just being in that space i just felt
like i had a much better sense of what
these habitats really look like
and how connected they are and whether
microbes and ingredients could flow from
one vent to the next
the thing that i would really value
whether i was present or not
is just being able to look at these
things longitudinally over time
understanding how the microbes adapt
over time is something we really haven't
addressed yet
and is something i'm working on right
now to try to understand better so there
i think there's a lot of value in that
now whether i would need to be
physically present for that period of
time is another question because i like
bathrooms and i like having food and
sunlight so
maybe not we enjoy the adventure of
going down there
but in the end we do want to sleep in a
soft bed that's not cold and damp at the
end of the day
the underwater habitats of the 20th
century have mostly been retired
a couple still remain serving scientists
but a focus on space exploration
and the rise of robotic technology has
decreased the need for humans
to live beneath the waves but could
there be
a resurgence fabian cousteau grandson of
jack
and an aquanaut explorer and
conservationist in his own right
spent 31 days underwater in 2014.
can you give me a sense of the science
that can be
achieved when you're underwater for
extended periods of time
my team and i were able to execute over
three years worth of equivalent
science as opposed to being based from
a ship above and that has a lot to do
with the access to the bottom world
by being able to be based out of an
underwater habitat
it's a very unique platform it's a very
unique tool
uh in the case of being saturated we
could dive
10 to 12 hours each of us per day
to take advantage of that and to be able
to do
uh much much more research in a workday
than you can from
the surface additionally as a human
being being
on right on the ocean's final frontier
you're able to do things that um that
simply are not
as easily accessible from an rov
or an auv or submersible
but there's still a human factor that
needs to
be integrated into these kinds of
exercises
and with mission 31 we were able to uh
use all sorts of of uh
laboratory equipment that normally are
relegated to a laboratory on land
and bring them back down to the bottom
of the sea
[Music]
fabian you're raising money for a new
underwater habitat called proteus
how is it different from the ones before
and why do we need it now
with proteus we're talking about a space
that is about 10
times the size of aquarius and
a team that will be twice the size
of any previous team deployed underwater
so about a dozen people
and with that we'll be testing the
physiological and psychological
parameters within which it's conducive
to deploy people for long periods of
time underwater
not days or weeks which has been done
many times before
but weeks months and maybe even longer i
anticipate a platform like proteus being
able to offer us a lot
more of that advanced technology on site
on the final frontier
at the bottom of the sea so that our
team can do
all of that research right there in real
time
and in the case of things like viral
pandemics
to be able to take those chemical
compositions of those
sets of of samples right there on site
and analyze them
and hopefully replicate them to
accelerate that research process
uh rather than having to send that
sample to the surface
have it potentially get corrupted and
get sent halfway around the world to sit
in a freezer
or a locker for months if not years
before it gets
analyzed
there's a small group of crazy people
like myself that that really believe in
this and
i think the the scientific community as
well is really excited
you